hi guys I'm Noah since a now and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
so this is actually I am Phoebe I'm Noah
since a nail is half a town and half
German
well actually it's half Italian Dutch
and we'll do Native American oh and
there's like Puerto Rican in there
somewhere which is fun it's actually me
yahoo answers fosters question so on the
last episode of the last season Ana
Mariana and hey Zeus got in a car crash
but in this season it appears that
nothing happened so was it all just
Steph's dream I'm really confused I'm
really confused too because I'm not the
writers I don't I know that it
definitely did happen though because
later on in the series there's PTSD from
it and also it ties into the plotline
with AJ that his brother is the one that
ran into the car that we were all in
boom next Twitter I know is sent what's
your most memorable experience from
filming Sarah Burgess as a loser and to
all the boys I've loved before
well dummy I can't have one favorite
experience from shooting two different
films and uh what is this tweet about I
said just because we've learned to count
to four does not mean we can understand
infinity well I was read a book called
blasphemy
the concept of me being able to say okay
one two three four and that pattern
going on forever is not the same thing
as infinity infinity is supposed to be a
concept of endlessness I have no idea
whatever it's fine oh I know his scent
what is the weirdest thing a fan has
done for you I don't really have an
answer to that yet it's all been very
like normal can I get an autograph
that's that's a new one someone was like
can I get a kiss on the cheek it's not
weird it's fantastic I love it yes you
can
replied I tweeted volunteers that never
drive staining today's canvas for
tomorrow's attention someone goes who
you on the answer is I hurt myself a
book my own heart on this one but yeah
it's fine I just tweeted let's take this
slower and a dear Kavinsky goes dude are
you talking about following Lana on
Instagram what - enough follow along on
Instagram I thought I did I totally
follow out on Instagram stop it stop
Wikipedia heard that Centeno start into
Netflix original teen comedy films in
2018 he portrayed the role of Peter
Kavinsky in the adaptation of Jenny Hans
romance novel to all the boys I've loved
before and the male lead in the upcoming
Sarah Burgess is a loser there's an
accurate it's just accurate sentences on
this screen right now I feel like this
might be the only time that Wikipedia
got something right it was actually
great because the same production
company that did to all the boys I loved
before is the same company that's doing
the standing they offered the role of me
so I didn't have to audition Cora what
the [ __ ] is Cora what are the most
unrealistic parts of to all the boys
I've loved before
20:18 movie one of them is that it took
Peter so long to like talk to Lara Jean
and like explain why he was in Jen's
room I would have liked not let her just
walk away I mean if she wanted to short
but then like I would have been able to
have an actual conversation way earlier
than waiting for the rest of winter
break to finish and blow over before
figuring out what happened you know more
clear I know a sense do you have a pet
peeve what is it
I got a few it used to be when I would
hold the door open for someone and then
they would just like hold their arm out
while they're walking through the doors
if I'm gonna slam it in their face but
then you realize like oh no they're just
like double checking and sharing that in
case something were to happen they want
to make sure that they're covered so I'm
not really upset when people do that
anymore I notice that what is your idea
of a romantic date anything that's not a
one-night stand like so much Twitter how
I can know is since narrow Drive like
this very simply Gigi
and yoga I know it's that so how did you
get into acting I was asked to audition
for an agent
I didn't even want to and then they
talked me into it and I did and then
just slowly went from there I can't
sleep so I decided to ask you questions
definitely he's gonna perpetuate the
issue of your insomnia if you were to
play in Olympic sport which sport would
you play soccer
totally I played soccer growing up I
played from like seven years old until I
turned 16
like when I moved out to LA I even
played for the high school but I would
totally play soccer in the Olympics that
is so fun Instagram
Kelsey McCoy can someone teach at and
sends an arrow how to wear clothes
it's adorably annoying no nobody can
ever teach no lesson today on how to
wear clothes because clothes are meant
to be worn by the wearer and the wearer
choose just how to walk posted it's
actually me Alanna posted a picture of
me and her cuddling on the couch during
our off time and between shooting the
hot tub scenes and la la la Alyssa a la
la
Alyssa la la la' Lissa I'm confused
there's an underscore at the end of it
underscore says can anyone tell me a
back story behind this photo or is this
just a photo they took for show crying
face emoji was it for show we were
shooting the hot tub scene and this must
have been right around the time that we
finished it because I stayed in the hot
tub for like five hours because I wanted
to it was really comfortable
there's nicely ten pit water and then we
were just hanging out on the couch and a
lot of and Israel had Polaroids I was so
tired because I was in the hot tub for
the entire time she was on the couch and
I just like crawled in her lap and then
she liked scratching my head her head
scratches feel really good we've seen
the underscore mandatory xoxo what are
you laughing about
what you're laughing about is actually
how she spelled it but I think she meant
what are you laughing I'm pretty sure
with this photographer Brian and I think
I said hey take a picture of this I'm
gonna laugh and it's gonna look super
candid
next wow that artwork where is this it's
right by the 101 cafe in Hollywood right
by where the 101
don't forget freeway crosses over
Franklin check it out
they don't like you when you take
pictures there though they will kick you
out be careful more Twitter are you a
Florida boy at heart or a Cali boy at
heart ish the kind of similar
mentalities I would say but Florida boy
for sure with tali influence no doubt
anyone else thinking that Noah since no
could have been a young Mark Ruffalo
just me it's not just you casting
directors always compare me to him I
even think that I could have been a
young Mark Ruffalo I even think I am
Mark Ruffalo and space and time is just
a weird thing that we can't understand I
want him to play the dad in the sequel
mark post it if there was only one book
you could read for the rest of your life
what would that book be and how did it
shape you as a person Shantaram
yeah Shantaram it's like the most recent
epic that I've read and it's poetic and
it's just such a beautifully crafted
book it's this this huge transition of
this person who was in jail and was
running from the law and then found his
own version of Nirvana and it's just a
fantastic book it really summarizes to
me what life is
but I'm 22 and I don't know what life is
don't listen to me seriously it's
actually me was that you actually
serving an SPF 18 ha no so much Twitter
I missed the 70s or something I tweeted
and someone said were you even alive
then no obviously not a 96 dog 22 get
off my back but I missed the 70s from
what everyone says it's a great period
of time that's it
that is it we're signing off the
internet
thanks guys